because from here the Russian President
Vladimir Putin is liable to arrest in
123 countries but no one will detain him
in Crimea the territory seized from
Ukraine in 2014 and he marked the
anniversary of its annexation with a
tour of this Art Center
this is good he says he looked unruffled
and Unapologetic and that was almost
certainly the point
what is it in total an art school asks
Putin
yes an art school and a children's camp
replies the priest we've agreed that
we'll select children that are very
talented
his visit came one day after the
international criminal court accused him
of abducting children from Ukraine to
Russia
but these allegations are dismissed by
his supporters in Crimea who were out
rallying and riding motorcycles in the
city of simpheropol here the president
enjoys the people's blessing
Crimean spring for nine years we are
together States this flag
the court has accused Putin and the
country's children's commissioner of the
forced deportation of children and it's
easily provable both have appeared on
television discussing it I think for
many uh international criminal lawyers a
a refreshing and encouraging sign that
prosecutor Khan is making a decision
here to prosecute first a case that he
knows he can prove with very little
difficulty but as I say more charges are
bound to follow
many leaders including the American
president have welcomed the decision of
the international Court
well I think it Justified this but the
question is it's not recognized
internationally by us either but I think
it makes a very strong point
Russia has been accused of committing
multiple human rights violations in
Ukraine including attacks on civilians
these missiles hit a place called
avdifka just after their Court announced
its indictment but the court has put
everyone on notice as this brutal
conflict grinds on the court and the
prosecutor have decided the indictment
should be made immediately public no
doubt to send a very clear signal that
those responsible for crimes in this war
will in due course be held accountable
in front of an international criminal
court
President Putin will not accept
responsibility and he won't present
himself for trial but he now celebrates
the annexation of Crimea as an
international fugitive from Justice
John Sparks Sky News